here in this Costa Rican rainforest the
Anolis lizards hungry Dan that's bad for
the local insect population a nearby
female is hungry as well luckily she's
in the process of shedding her old skin
which provides additional nutrition the
male notices the female at this point
the Costa Rican rainforest becomes
something like a singles hangout he
notices that she's on his turf she
doesn't scram when he moves in which
means she's open to being courted now he
doesn't have a sports car to impress her
but he does have a flashy rust-colored
inflatable throat sack he's capable of
doing this for hours
looks like it's not gonna take hours you
can tell she's impressed they mate
upside down clinging to the tree
probably the first of many matings like
male humans for their cute girlfriend
the male analyst is all puffed up over
it